ich habe mal wieder auf Ebay in 400 €
Amazon Paket für 200 € gekauft und das
war drin ja das sind safe also ich bin
ja mittlerweile echt vertraut mit so
Retouren aber das sind niemals es sei
denn okay das habe ich noch nicht
ausgepackt also da muss hier in diesem
Paket schon echt was teures drin sein
okay wir starten einfach mal hier mit
das Dingen kann man in der Dusche
befestigen und dann da sein Duschzeug
und so rein bauen dieses Ding kostet bei
Amazon safe nicht mehr als 50 oder 60 €
dann machen wir hier weiter wir haben
drei Mal ein Satelliten bin ich mal
gespannt kenne ich mich auch nicht
wirklich mit aus schauen wir mal nach
sorry ich nehme alles zurück ein
Satellit kostet tatsächlich bei Amazon
105 €. das ist echt schon damit hätte
ich nicht gerechnet
eine Tastatur die aber auf jeden Fall
schon mal benutzt wurde kostet neu bei
Ebay 35 €. ich würde jetzt mal lieb
gemeinte sechs von zehn Sterne geben
dafür mehr ist auf jeden Fall leider
nicht